how we move forward collectively while
addressing the racism that is being
perpetuated I certainly am not making
any excuses for this guy you can also
tell that the man has been severely
brainwashed as time goes on with each
successive interview he sounds more and
more like a 55 year old white woman
holding a corporate diversity seminar
problematic perpetuating racism move
forward collectively and then my
favorite navigate these spaces no human
being naturally speaks that way a former
athlete especially does not speak that
way you're not going to hear a football
player in the locker room listen fellas
there's a lot of problematic Behavior
going on in here we really need to
figure out how to navigate these spaces
so we can move forward collectively
respecting each other's lived
experiences so that we can unpack our
oppression and curate an understanding
of our intersectional realities and
together come up with solution-oriented
perspectives liberated from our
post-colonial trauma it's just not how
human beings speak okay rather it's how
a Dei robot is programmed